[Music]
what are the 10 best Godzilla designs
yeah that's the question and yeah I know
it's subjective everyone has their own
pick and their own favorite Godzilla
incarnations but what are actually the
best based on three things size having a
scary or a fearsome appearance and a
proper body part size proportions that
is appearing to be realistic without
diving in too much into the Fantasy
Realm well let's take a look at our
pics at number 10 we have Godzilla Earth
this is the biggest Godzilla that has
ever graced the screens he's here on the
top 10 list mainly due to his size and
his great range of powers but his body
proportions however are not exactly that
realistic meaning his arms tail and legs
as well as the upper TSO is greatly
Divergent from a Godzilla that we think
of he also doesn't seem to bring out any
horror element something which is
actually lacking but mainly due to him
being in an animated movie rather than a
life action
one number nine Godzilla Millennium this
Godzilla Millennium from 1999 is small
in size relatively speaking that is he
is 55 M or 180 ft tall he is indeed
scary looking with a mouth full of
saltlike teeth and his skin texture is
spiky his downsides however ever are the
oversized pinkish dorsal plates which
appears to be crystalline in nature
otherwise he has an okay body design and
that's why he's on still on the top 10
list another feature that puts this Goji
lower down on the list is his skin
texture which has kind of a dark green
Hue or a highlight which is greatly
Divergent from the traditional
coloration which is black or gray number
eight Godzilla gmk this Godzilla is The
Reincarnation of the maset Souls of
World War II and he is the only version
that has a supernatural origin story he
is small in size but scary as with
whitish pupiless eyes and a mouth full
of saltlike teeth with two distinct
upper canines that make him look like a
saber-tooth cat other than that he has
an okay body proportion with the legs
arms and tail being in proper order and
not so freakishly large or small in
ratio to the
Torso number seven Godzilla Tokyo SOS
also known as KIRO Goji this design is a
great improvement over the earlier 200
Millennium version the head was
completely changed and made smaller to
the point of resembling the head of the
haay Godzilla the Dorsal fins were
reduced a bit and lost their purplish
Hue retaining the classic bone white
coloration he was made to be a bit
bigger at 60 M or 200 ft tall and has
now retained the charcoal black skin
color all these changes as well as the
animatronics included in his head
allowed him for some facial expressions
of surprise shock or anger th pushing up
the list to number
seven number six hyay Godzilla the first
of the H era Godzilla designs has a good
size of around 80 M or 262 ft tall and
grew to be 100 m at the end of the era
he doesn't appear to be so scary at
first but then he became scary by the
time he faced dest Royer but then as per
our standards in the 1980s I suspected
that he was scary to the people back
then he has an okay body design meaning
body parts were all in line with a
Godzilla that we think of but the head
was way too big to give off a menacing
look at first otherwise that was also
Changed by the time he faced destoy in
1995 his later improved body that was
seen in versus destoy seems to have
corrected all that was lacking in the
1984 form he is in fact what most of us
think when we hear the the word
godzilla number five Shin Godzilla this
ever evolving Godzilla is truly a unique
take on the Kaiju in his fourth form he
possesses the size of around 118.5 M or
around 390 ft he has a black reddish
skin coloration which changed from his
earlier um lesser darker tones he also
has relatively smaller dosel plates he
is scary as hell though especially with
that face that seems to be some sort of
a lovecrafting creature if you think
about it but then again due to his very
unique design his body parts were
greatly out of ratio for example the
tail was extra long and has some sort of
demonic looking end that can also shoot
the atomic breath and the hands are tiny
relative to the body or the Torso
otherwise without those without these
changes Shin Godzilla would have easily
topped the list at number four we have
the original original Godzilla of
1954 so the original Godzilla should
logically be the Benchmark to set the
scales he is the primogenitor of all the
other Godzilla designs since without him
there won't be any other ones and he was
the first one although appearing scary
as hell back in the day in 1954 he was
still a man in a suit and this OG design
can be thought of as a prototype meaning
that enhancements and improvements were
imminent as the time passes by he is
small at 50 m of 65 ft in height and
comes in black and
white number three the monsterverse
Godzilla so the titanis goera Titan here
is obviously one of the biggest in size
coming first at 108 M or 355 ft tall in
2014 and then grew to be 120 M or 393 ft
tall in the sequence of kotm in GVK his
overall design looks scary especially in
GVK with the glowing atomic energy that
seems seems to be seeping out from his
body from every pore in his body the
dosel plates of the 2014 version was
straight and Jagged while the latter
ones were more Maple Leaf in design
which was an improvement I might say but
then again he doesn't really have that
horror element in him while the plus
points are the ratio of the body parts
to his torso which are awesome uh at
least we can all agree to that if we
ignore the pinkzilla form that will be
seen in the next year's gxk movie number
two
Godzilla minus one the most recent
Godzilla to appear in the big screens
breaks records wherever he is seen and
he is here in the second spot as well it
isn't just the storyline and the movie
plot that makes this Godzilla minus one
to top the charts and be awesome it is
also his scary design which I might say
along with Shin Godzilla is the scariest
of them all he has a perfect body with
thick legs slender arms ending in a
talon-like Claws and a deadly tail with
a row of dosel plates that simply cry
out death and destruction his face gives
everyone the chills being both
animalistic and Sinister at the same
time which can be animated to portray
his dark emotions if not for the smaller
size which is just .1 M taller than the
OG he would have been at the number one
spot and number one Godzilla from Final
Wars my favorite of all time and I'm
honest enough to say that him being at
the top of the list is is a bit biased
really but let me justify it he has an
awesome size of 100 m or 328 ft in
height bigger than most other Godzillas
and bigger than Godzilla minus one as
well he's also scary as hell taking
elements from the earlier H and gmk
designs and incorporating them perfectly
he has an angry demeanor appearing to be
indifferent to all kaijus and even
Humanity as well therefore he can be
thought of as the epitome of the
godsilla character his arms legs and
Tails are also created to make him look
powerful and athletic as well but that's
what I think personally that's why he's
the best here but be free to write down
your own list in the comments section
below so that's the end of the video now
if you like this one then watch this
other one as well and do check out our
Channel as we might have monsterverse
things and guide you things that you
haven't seen before like subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video take
care
[Music]
fam